good evening wild weather here in the
southwest tonight here in town some
showers wind this is not too far from
Durango and Warm Springs a really great
video you can just see it coming down in
sheets some bad flooding though also
reported in Moapa this is coming in by
our viewer this is Delfina and Shonda
take a look at this video here of all
that water collection her backyard in a
Lytle Ranch looking kind of more like a
shallow Pond and if you look a little
closer her neighbor's yard she's kind of
panning around here also flooded she
says it's really been a big safety
hazard because it's really difficult to
get around with all that excess water
and finally take a look at this
incredible video this is a swift water
rescue happened earlier tonight in
Bullhead City as we've had a very wet
winter for this region this is an
important reminder of course just about
the dangers of fast moving water that
man clinging to a tree waiting to be
rescued Crews eventually made their way
over to him using a crane and a ladder
truck but boy it was a touch and go
there during that rescue